Speaker 1: OK, so I want to lay this out now
just to get it on the record relatively early.
Normally, I don't comment about an election
that's not the immediate next election.
So in 2017, people would call in and they'd
say, hey, what do you think about 2020?
This, that?
And I'd say, we have to focus on twenty eighteen.
That's the immediate question right now.
What happens in twenty eighteen.
But I actually do want to talk about twenty
twenty four today a little bit because I worry
that there's lots of people just missing what's
taking place and not seeing what is increasingly
a very disturbing situation.
The bottom line is this.
I believe that if there's a so-called rematch
in twenty four between Trump and Biden, that
that's very, very bad for Joe Biden.
I don't think that looks good.
And if Joe Biden chooses not to run for reelection
and it is Kamala Harris instead, who is the
Democratic presidential nominee, I think that
that also doesn't look very good.
And I'm going to lay out why now.
I'm going to mention Joe Biden's age here.
Joe Biden would be 82 at the time of the twenty
twenty four election.
Donald Trump would also be 78 at that time.
And one might argue there's really not that
much difference.
It's just two old white guys.
But the difference is that Donald Trump has
a cult of followers, a cult of personality
around him that afflicts his supporters for
whom Trump's age is not going to be a factor.
While I believe that because of the nature
of Joe Biden's support and because of the
nature, particularly of the progressive wing
of the Democratic Party and the preferences
of Democratic voters, the idea of voting for
and 82 year old in 2024 is going to impact
those more predisposed to vote for Joe Biden.
Then it will affect those likely or considering
voting for Donald Trump in twenty, twenty
four.
So in other words, what I'm saying is Biden's
age will work against him more than Trump's
age will work against Trump.
So let's now get into my thought process.
First and foremost, I'm getting the sense
just at a basic level, that in general, a
so-called rematch is going to be very tough
for Joe Biden.
And in addition to the concept of a rematch
or one of our Redit viewers put a post up
on our Redit that calls it like a sort of
final showdown, I think that it will invigorate
the right far more than it will invigorate
the left.
That's one scenario, the final showdown rematch
between Trump and Biden.
I don't think it's very good for Joe Biden.
Now, there's a different scenario that's possible,
which is that Joe Biden, as some suspect,
might not run for a second term in 2024 and
then Kamala Harris will either be handed or
might have to fight for the Democratic nomination.
There's still a long time until 2024, but
all of those scenarios, I think, are also
problematic.
Kamala Harris has maintained a relatively
low profile so far, and she has low approval
ratings.
That doesn't give me much confidence about
Harris vs. Trump in twenty twenty four.
If you look at the latest real Clear Politics
average of approval polls, Kamala Harris is
now underwater.
Her negatives, her disapproval is higher than
her approval.
For better or worse, she's taken some real
hits when it comes to her handling of the
border.
Now, you might say what handling?
Rightly or wrongly, Joe Biden tasked her with
the border problem.
Her approval on that is very low now.
It's early.
Things could change between now and twenty,
twenty four.
But as of right now, I am not at all confident
that if Kamala Harris is just handed the Democratic
nomination, meaning Biden says, I'm not running,
but Kamala Harris is running and no serious
Democratic primary takes place and she's the
nominee.
I don't think Harris does well against Donald
Trump in twenty twenty four.
In fact, I find it really difficult to see
a scenario where she wins.
Now, the other scenario would be Joe Biden
says he's not running and Harris does run.
But there's a big primary fight, which Kamala
Harris ultimately wins because of her low
approval if Kamala Harris has to fight her
way through an ugly primary to get that nomination.
It also strikes me as a recipe for disaster
similar to 2016.
The third scenario would be Biden doesn't
run.
Comilla fights for the nomination, but she
loses and someone else is the Democratic nominee.
That I do think is too early to talk about.
And we just have no idea who that might be.
We have no idea how they might match up against
Donald.
It's just too hypothetical.
But the two scenarios I'm focused on, which
are the problematic ones, which are Biden
does run for reelection or Biden doesn't and
Carmela's the nominee, whether she just gets
it handed to her or she fights for it and
wins it, if you give me an even money bet
today.
I'm probably betting on Trump in those scenarios
based on what I currently see as the energy
of the Democratic Party and the energy of
the Republican Party, part of it is that even
in 20, 20, right.
There's this urgent emergency of removing
Donald Trump.
The the the energy and enthusiasm around Biden
was relatively muted.
Now, Biden, fortunately won by many millions
of votes nationally, but it was small differences
in just a few states.
If they had gone the other way, Trump would
have won.
It's similar to Trump winning in 16.
If just a few states went slightly differently,
Hillary Clinton would have been the winner
in 2016.
So that also makes me concerned with Trump
four years in the rearview mirror that there
will be, again, Democrats who, after eight
years of Obama said, I'm not out for whatever
reason.
I'm not going to go out and vote in this Hillary
versus Trump thing.
And then Trump won.
A repeat of that also scares me.
And then in addition to that, as we see at
these Trump rallies, the cult of personality
around Donald Trump, the fact that the Republican
Party, whether they're pretending or whether
they seriously like Trump, it doesn't matter.
They're basically behind him.
They're not abandoning him.
That is troubling.
And there is really I mean, it really seems
like there's nothing Trump can do to lose
the support that he has, or at least most
of it.
So I think twenty, twenty four is real trouble
in a rematch against Joe Biden or against
Kamala Harris?
I'm not saying I have a better idea.
I think Trump will be very strong in twenty
four if he's the nominee.
So if you have a different perspective, I
would love to hear from you.
And I understand I'm breaking my own rule.
I usually only talk about the next election,
but the circumstances are unique and the next
election is 20 two.
But it relates so much to twenty four that
we really have sort of like a three year period
that I see as a package in my mind.
So send me your thoughts about this.
And of course, if twenty, twenty two goes
disastrously for the Trump wing of the Republican
Party, that weakens Trump dramatically.
But I don't know that that's actually going
to be the outcome.
So let me know how worried you are about this.
If you agree, disagree, find me on Twitter
at David Pakman.